I almost got cancelled about a year and
a half ago uh oh and uh I to the club
it's so fun but I posted a picture I
posted a picture it's above the the
thing there I didn't know what this is
like in the midst of uh covid I saw this
picture did not know did not recognize
what it was I don't either good so a
doctor doesn't I rest my case I posted
it why are there out it's a prolapsed
anus oh yes it is well see they didn't
know that but I I I it looked like to me
that that thing that's the prolap just
looked like a cerebral hemisphere like a
brain he thought it was a cupcake I love
that you don't know your brain from your
oh it's so good no but so I
didn't know what it was my son who was
sitting right there called me uh you
know an hour later and said Dad uh
you've posted something on Tik Tok it's
got it's trending World wide take it
down I lost a couple of sponsors and I
got but you should have been celebrated
why why because you were first of all
you were celebrated on H3 you were
celebrated I do I've been many times in
there yeah and and I used to try to make
help Ethan understand um Trisha but uh
which when they were together when it
was the FR ofies thing uh but I think
the a you're you're goofing around and
you did something naive and it and if
people actually cared about what you
were doing they should just go hey hey
come on howwi let me help you this did
you know that that's probably as opposed
to oh the outrage we have this we have
grandiose outrage and grandiose caring
right now and that is not actually
caring that's just expressing your need
to be seen and heard which is a
narcissistic it trended worldwide and
for you should have said you been Maya
culpan it should have been a good joke
which is your comedian it's funny oh I
wasn't even I just said it's a covid
related I just didn't know if it what
what it was I thought it was a
cupcake funnier I will post this picture
right now show them the squirr I have a
squirrel it's even funny okay so there's
there's a squirrel I are you allowed to
post that it's a squirrel little more
like a prolapse do you talk about this
stuff all the time on this show I think
feel like I'm in a new territory you
haven't watched our show not l i i watch
a lot of know pieces of it I guess I've
not got the part where the anal prolapse
comes in well it's not it's not big part
mostly that it's just to keep our minds
off the fact that I left her at the
circus but anyway this is a squirrel
with a prolaps anus it looks like it
yeah it is so I want to know like here's
what I want to know and I'm asking you
as a doctor yes I went on Ethan's show I
went on H3 and he was
very you know excited to talk to me
about this he let it run much longer
than I would have let it run the whole
prolapse thing I was trying to forget it
yeah and then he brought on this guy
hunger what what's the guy's name what's
the guy's name do you guys remember his
name no one no okay I'm glad that my
staff is so well but I didn't realize
that there is a sexual Community there's
a there's a there's a line of preference
I guess yeah there's a world where
people can actually and I don't know
that this is not it taken up in the
squirrel Community where they can
actually do this it's not a problem
where you can turn yourself inside out
and enjoy it yeah there there I've seen
that your mom's house is it's your mom's
house they they've gone way my mom's
house no no no this is Tom sigur's your
mom house oh okay I'm Bubba's doing
it your grandmother can okay go ahead
her own okay what did you
see uh they they they've been way into
this for quite for years oh so I'm
behind no pun intend and they've they
like to show me things that make me
ashamed and feel bad and this that was a
whole line that they are you ashamed of
seeing a squirrel stuff that they showed
me was pretty extreme no this is for the
children and I when I see it's nuts but
here's my thing when I see that I don't
know about squirrel rectums but when I
see adult you know male and female with
that induce that I just think that
person is going to have a I'm not a
coloral surgeon but I have sent people
to surgery for that many times but when
you say for that yeah the up until I did
Ethan show yeah this was explained to me
like a problem where you know you're his
name is hunger pardon me his name is
hunger oh just hunger Hunger um it was
explained to me as a problem where your
your your inerts are falling out correct
as you get older again women
particularly they get prolapse of their
vagina of their uterus and sometimes of
the anus and the rectum and when the
rectum falls through like the people
like doing in this line of uh practice
it can cut off its own blood supply it
can sort of it's coming through a small
what are you doing with your fists I'm
showing an anus as with a prolapse
through it it and it is that the anus
right there the anus it's also can we
zoom in on the anus ready site it's also
s he has an accent do it because we're
zooming in on has an
accent okay well okay go ahead you can
speak with your ass I I'm just saying
Senor Wes it's you Senor Wes you're me
too that I so um it were I always think
oh my God if these people are not going
to need an emergency surgery because of
hemia of the region because of blood
supply issues eventually they're going
to end up with a big surgery these are
Big surgeries they're not fun but people
are doing it he so he brought this guy
hunger on the show I Know Who as a you
know no I know they're doing it did he
make you do it did he do it for you in
person he went 1 two three like I was a
judge on America Scot not in person on a
video why watching why are we watching
that's from just your mom's house right
or is that what he did that's not my
mom's house stop saying my mom how about
the fact that this could be a line of
talent for America's Got Talent that's
you mentioned that that all blew my mind
yeah but why how do you your daughter is
quite serious about this she's they
should have on only fans America's Got
Talent where people could do that no no
we just saw something and I'm sure
Jeremy did that Jeremy did you do that
no no hang on use that mind for good
please just use that M for good please I
can't hear you jerem not for me boot leg
footage from Ethan's birthday Ethan's
birthday yeah yeah so he had that on
we're not showing that though that's a
little much but that's the stuff that
your mom's house shows that kind of
stuff all the time to you to me and goes
what do you think yeah but I'm not
asking you what you think what I'm
saying is cuz I know what I think it's
it's it's seems wrong uh don't don't
yuck someone's yum there's no yum in
that don't judge let's do it
non-judgmentally judge non-judgmentally
I am a
judge see keep Jack keep going down that
path you you might you might have
something here can you imagine if you're
long covid at the end of it you go I can
learn languages and I can do that no
thank you you can prolapse on command
what what if he tried yeah you never you
don't know until you try but ever since
I saw that I've been um I'm going to be
honest well no I've been afraid like uh
when you take a when you have B you're
afraid I almost I've almost become
constipated because I don't want to push
it's not going to happen it's not going
to happen how do you know you said it
when you're older I don't want that to
happen I don't want to be on H3 with
that
Talent males tend to be have more
musculature in that area so it really
doesn't happen froming those were males
doesn't happen from pushing when during
a bom move it happens from more active
sorts of things happening okay B much
larger
things